welcome everyone to the Thursday evening
class and this class is basically on a
really nice game played in a 21st
century that's the theme on this and
this game is actually pretty recent
played less than a year ago in a Qatar
Masters Tournament it's a very strong
super tournament a lot of strong players
playing it in Qatar and this game is by
world champion Carlson against Li Chiao
so you could imagine how strong is that
open tournament sort of that they could
recruit the world champion to play in it
so it's a very very prestigious
tournament so c4 g6 do we know that
opening at the moment or it's still kind
of unknown
excellent so we don't know the opening
yet okay so it's a could be a groom felt
or it could be yeah
all right so f3 this is a very modern
way of playing against it because trying
to prevent a very modern modern way of
playing against this opening they're
trying to stop this d5 ideas and just
white wants to play e4 to get the
control of the center okay so f3 idea is
to play E for most likely you know Li
Chiao I think so yeah believe he's the
groom field player so that's why Magnus
Carlsen played f3 and this is going to
lead to some very sharp positions so
take 95 e 496 this is all theory thus
far moving bit fast Queen d2 and
normally wife will go for long castle in
this position and try to attack very
quickly with h4 h5 so 96 is one option
another possibility here is e 5e 5 d 5 c
6h war and it gets really really complex
very sharp lines so HR played 96 this is
a little bit less a little bit less
sharp so now along castle and now f5
besides this book there is some other
possible in this position for black but
f5 is just trying to weaken the position
of the center and try to gain some
activities ePHI by the world champion
logical move to shut down the bishop now
this bishop is not going to come out and
but the problem is what is the problem
that you see now after this move e5
exactly d4 is sort of backwards and the
week d5 square so now what black is
going to try to do he's going to try to
base his whole play for the rest of the
game on this d5 squared that's what he's
planning to do so 94 now controlling the
d5 square Knight h3 the point is to go
Knight to f4 okay Queenie e8 King b1
idea of king b1 is to play a three to
put pressure on the knight a five Bishop
e2 Carlson is just developing but Li
Chiao he knows this opening he's one of
the experts of the green field defense
so it's not just the guy who is playing
guqin fault he's you know really an
authority in the opening as well so and
it's going to be getting really really
messy in a second you'll see look see
one white is trying to a little bit
consolidate make sure the King is not
too weak King goes on h8 because he
wants to go Bishop e6 and if it's
attacked he wants to maybe hide on g8
and just move away King a worm it should
be six in our Queen f7
so now black is just threatening to take
the pawn yes you can take only six but
after Queenie six you don't have that
much black has excellent grip on d5 and
it's not so clear if you how you're
going to try to proceed so now let's see
if you can find the best move here for
white what do you think why should try
to do here to continue his attack
perhaps d5 no but then it takes it loses
upon and if I pawn is becoming weak too
so unfortunately d5 it will just go on I
bd5 and it's going to get a little bit
weak a two is weak if you Phoebe three
you run into a four if you play three so
it's just yet becoming a problem okay
h4 bishop a - this is where the fun
stuff will start now cross and give up
his pawn who was seen on helping to
shield his king and now h5 attacking on
g6 now there's a pressure on g6 and King
g8 crossing took took he precisely
calculated
of course you don't be forgiving up when
he precisely calculated what's going to
happen by the way why g5 wasn't played
it looks logical why this move wasn't
played can you tell me yes in the back
since raise your hand yeah guys yes 9 g6
very nice check if capture a curse H
takes jisuk Shak King has the move
picking out the Queen and winning the
game very nice
so that's why you play King g8 and now
capture and what should he do here how
he should try to proceed here with the
attack what do you think
what do you think white can do any ideas
and it gets yes food is a possibility
and that is what he played absolutely
Bravo
yeah g4 try to open up the position
Carson is going all out because what
else to do yeah it's not so clear this
d5 is not working if 6 is not working
see they're not really working anything
so he's trying to open up the G file for
this loop to come in this should be
three buddy Chow trying to perhaps you
know have some threats via night c2 now
Bishop d1 play by the world champion now
controlling the c2 square but most
importantly now look what he wants to do
queen h2 27 it's got very serious threat
Cena now if one slow move Queen h2 Queen
h7 is going to be a checkmate okay so
that is what's going on here
one slow move and Queen h2 n h7 will win
the game a for protecting the bishop and
trying to play now 83 to open up really
a really important moment to play
correctly what is the next move
you absolutely queen h2 rook da that's
what he's planning to do he wants to
vacate vacate that f8 square for this
game now he's winning but he has to be
precise so can you be precise and win
this game like the world champion
aha see you trying to say 96 but look at
that move
look at that clearance move attacking
this night
absolutely brilliant move d5 its
disconnecting the communication now
attacking the night if the night
captures is six look what he wants to do
I mean this is beautiful
attacks checks and checks and I mean
he's just I mean there are other ways to
win of course but this is just just a
checkmate on effect so he calculated all
this so so after the five leach I
realized that he's probably gonna lose
now
so he didn't see anything better you
know because he didn't see anything
better than just to go here now really a
very powerful and energetic victory very
energetic victory for the world champion
so now how are you going to finish him
off here huh ninety-six stay with the
program right you came there to win the
pond now he goes hidden now absolutely
very nice job attacking the Queen kun
cannot be sacrificed or actually sorry
this this is a mate actually decided and
do that I mean it seems like let's just
check this and the same thing yeah guys
this just clear fate will be unstoppable
mate so that's why he decided to play
this move amazing yeah amazing idea and
what he is trying to do he wants to do
his own checkmate here or at least some
kind of perpetual so he took the Queen
king daeso your damn entire Queen here
but you know blocks got that bishop now
open it's got some threads here and it's
got like one two three four five you see
five pieces and a pawn
that's serious stuff right there now if
you don't know what you're going to
you can lose this very quickly so what
he should do here what do you think like
for example some people may take and
then they get made it you know it's not
out of the question yeah so
check this is a nice move it's basically
he's blocking the bishop if the knight
goes away then not too much attacking
power so Bishop has to take Queen a5
check this is all the moves so it was
here and now this Bishop is very
powerful it's too strong here and it
needs to be eliminated okay
and once this Bishop is eliminated then
his attack will lose its strength and
here's what did the world champion play
to do that do you see what he can try to
do to eliminate it in the back
absolutely and now let's take this
patient best way to eliminate the pieces
that attacking do is just eliminate them
by taking them check King bee to see how
he skillfully you know eliminated both
bishops now he doesn't have the bishops
none also check by the chow he goes back
take c1 rook takes c1
without the bishops is very difficult to
construct any kind of mating net King c8
this is completely hopeless but he just
played a couple of more moves so now it
took connecting his Bishop f4 attacking
the knight and here he resigned the game
because he cannot take this pomp Bishop
e6 check taking on g4 and just nothing
can be done here who can say when after
a fall you lose the night you lose the
night and + f7 is protected
so this pawns are simply gonna march
down and win the game alright so this
was a beautiful win for the world
champion wind up actually winning the
tournament he didn't win clear first it
was a tie for first with another Chinese
Grandmaster you young he and he managed
to defeat you young in the playoffs so
China has some very strong players as
you can see today the England won this
game against fiddler very nice game and
they have the child they have you you
young G they have some other satisfy day
they do really well in the Olympiad so
China is a great team they have okay
very good now I'm going to make sure you
guys remember this entire game 36 moves
okay so we're going to see how well you
understand the ideas of the world
champion okay so let's start from the
first move
so so the first thing you remember d4 c4
and let's start from here on let's see
if you remember yes in the back f3 what
is that why they play this setup
remember I explained to you they trying
to yeah but wait yeah why they play the
setup to e4 avoid the theory so d5 we
capture captures and now what do you
play d4 Knight c3 let me get this few
natural moves out and now this is the
moment when you play this system you
need to remember and understand get you
aiming for castle okay you aiming for
castle that's exactly what you're aiming
for okay Catholic right so remember that
that's your plan to simply castle okay
f-five now putting pressure on your
Center if he takes takes he goes some
Bishop g4 ideas it's going to be some
problem so what are you going to do now
what are you going to do to prevent that
from happening
very good excellent shutting down the
bishop what's the drawback do you know
the drawback about this move d5 in
particular yeah DeForest David backward
as well but in particular d5 square is
now on the blocks control night before
display
what did call some player members night
actually first remember and now can be
won a five remember he wants to
consolidate his position a little bit
here so this should be Q Bravo one more
consolidating move to make sure he is
defending everything rook c1 I believe
he played rook c1 no okay a little
freeze for a second it will come back on
okay yeah
King a one King h8 and now I'm sorry
King a funny Bishop e6 and now this is
the moment this is the time to start the
attack because if you hesitate a little
bit more he's going to have a successful
attack on you when you see opposite
counter cancelling right when he cancels
this way you cancelled our way that's
opposite side counseling what that
usually means who knows this answer what
does that mean if players Castle a
opposite side what it's likely to happen
yes they're going to attack each other
on the opposite sides of the board so
puck is now pushing this direction and
you can say Carlson is pushing the other
direction and whoever is faster whoever
reaches the opponent's king faster he's
going to win the game and in this game
you see that it was a world champion but
his King was also in some trouble there
but he was always in command so Knight
f4 comes in and also remember when you
play the system with f3 against the
groom felt h4 is part of your plan this
h4 h5 is part of your plan that you're
going to play okay so it's very
important that you remember that you're
going to play it for H virus up
so it goes here Bishop a two now taking
the pawn h5 there is no time to hesitate
or try to do something else this is the
moment to simply to go for it okay no
time to hesitate
now if g5 everybody remembered in this
room the winning move Knight g6
brilliant check
he takes H text winning there the Queen
the game yeah hit the play King G it
oh well then Knight xfa then g g5 is
also hanging you losing too much
material there so he went King g8 right
away now you want to open up the H file
as soon as possible
ASAP oh okay take take and now G for no
hesitation now you want to take on f5
bring the rook into the game but also
what other very important purpose this
move has that we saw in the game
happening yes absolutely
opens the second round so we can swing
the Queen here and eventually to our
desired square on h7 to be able to win
so it goes Bishop d1 we should be
three-story threating some knight see to
check ideas so how are we going to get
this Queen there eventually
we should be one not only this is a
great defensive move taking care of this
issues here but it's also now clearing
the square for the Queen to go to a four
Queen h2 threatening checkmate in one on
h7 the only way to stop it is to go King
to rook to d8 check here
d5 now that's a fantastic let's see how
many players here you think they would
consider something like that that's a
that's a very powerful move that's like
a that's a clearance move that you're
clearing the square for your Bishop but
most importantly what he's achieving is
that he is going to be able to play the
move if six so that's what is really
achieving by playing the movie five very
strong move this is a very strong
Grandmaster move d5 because a lot of
people would be we could get carried
away by just grabbing the material and
trying to do something else but you
don't want to do that okay you want to
go for the mate and in order to do that
you're going to need to have this pawn
on e6 if you want to make him okay so it
was 94 attacking the bishop and now 96
check King comes here he's six attacking
the Queen now if it goes Queen f6 check
okay Jade and mate on a fait unstoppable
so he goes a tree trying to open up the
position she takes f7 check King V seven
think about it a little bit 95 yes see
it's not too late not too late to make a
bad move like Bishop takes beat three
and after check get mated like this that
would have been a really terrible way to
lose yes exactly that's what I mentioned
yes
you getting deflect the knife from c4 is
too powerful excellent move again by a
champion and now his wants to take on c4
so he has to take check you know it's
it's a really a brilliant game he wins
the Queen he's up at Queen for free but
then he has to sacrifice a knight first
then he has to come back and sacrifice
his queen and it's almost equal material
now yeah material wise if you count it's
equal I guess yeah now he just takes the
bishop so it looks kind of equal it
feels like there might be some other
ways also to try to win but I mean this
is definitely the cleanest just win the
bishop takes now there is no mating
mechanism in this kind of positions you
can really come up with some you know
you can try to go check but just just
king comes to be one and if he goes here
now check
now we are taking and now we are taking
his rook on a tree so I can do that so
he goes Knight check can get one takes
rook takes on c1 and now king c8 well 93
just loop the one and you're going to
have to move your night back this is
completely losing and after a full HR
resigned in the view of you know Bishop
this X is coming geez just 67 so it was
really really nice game by the champion
in are really brilliant victory against
lechero is a very serious competitor
with 2750 rating so he wasn't just
beating in a regular restaurant jam this
world-class player here with the high
ranking like that okay well any
questions you have about this game
anybody everybody understand
it was a fast dynamic game with each
move was very important one slow move
one hesitant move could have resulted in
opposite person getting checkmated all
right very good now I have a end game
study puzzle for you that I want to set
up and see if you guys can try to solve
this very interesting endgame study okay
let me set it up we do a little bit of
end games at the end okay
how many people like to do studies
studies are positions that they're not
actually played in the tournament
they're just composed by people who like
to compose studies so this is a study
and looks like white is in trouble
because there is a checkmate idea coming
here and you know some problem by the
way that today was a game played he
could have been ended something similar
yeah Khurana game against Hikaru was you
know they had they had some material
similar to this just couple more puns
but of course here block is threatening
some serious ideas with Queen h3 so
you're gonna need to come up with an
idea not to lose this game okay
try to come up with an idea to save this
and make a draw okay so what can we do
here to accomplish that so I'm going to
give you a couple of minutes to think
and when you read it please raise your
hand
don't say the move yet okay please raise
your hand you know the threat it's Queen
h3 mate okay that is the threat
Quinn is very strong and the rooks are
connecting connected to each other if
they move around then it's possible with
the checks you're going to lose it so
that's the problem here
okay we have one student erasing yes
what's that move kingi - he says miss
check
check checkmate
look here here seems like this might be
losing no and what do we call this in
chess soups one you've got Luke's one
yes Rosie - wait wait wait you already
had your chance wait wait check all
right okay great okay what's the
question now okay well a little bit more
specific okay let's not be too casual
here let's be a little bit more specific
okay maybe it's a rock move it is a rock
more because King move loses but which
route where got two rocks
I need somebody who has the solution all
the way through okay
it's one two three four it's four moves
only and it ends with a still made hint
for you big hint four moves and it ends
with a steal mate the first ball is very
important to play because if you don't
play the correct move you might just
simply get into some trouble so the
first one is very important do you see
why we cannot move this rook up Wendy to
check wins the rock right
perfect that makes sense okay we have
one student here yes what's the move can
you be more specific
which rook rook ge1 perfect well other
one this blunders made perfect okay now
in order to win he has to give a check
or do something like this right
check check it to the king now he's
gonna try to come up here and announce
the checkmate don't rush don't rush what
is the move here you have to be precise
still king h1 correct not rook g1 that's
what I was hoping to lure you in and
play King HT win rook c3 correct
decision rookie three fortress yeah if
it doesn't take if it doesn't take you
just go home key trick protecting so it
has to take and rookie three he takes
and the king is trapped so what do we
call this still make excellent good one
huh naughty very easy one but it was
good it was very good for you for this
class to do it okay next one good job
we're going to move forward there were a
couple of other very interesting ones
that I want to show you this one this
one in particular looks looks very
interesting
let's see white to play and win
can you can you imagine you're gonna win
this he's got 3 pounds he's got 3 pounds
yeah yeah he's got 3 pounds but he's got
3 pounds okay we have moisture it's very
concrete though this is very concrete
idea if you don't do it concrete then
it's not so clear so you have to
concrete calculate calculate ideas
well let's not rush here let's not rush
maybe but - lets not rush let's try to
find okay we have weight same student
again let's see let's see maybe other
good players we have here let's see if
maybe they have a chance to find let's
see calculate this one is one two three
four yeah five for about four or five
bucks six move mate yes what's the move
Knight to c5 interesting idea but I
think this is not the correct move
because can see it now if you go Knight
is sex I go rook g8 and I protect so
severe drop so you really have one move
here one chance one opportunity here to
get this done but how how to do this
what is the precise way to finish this
off it's a mekinese mating a mechanism a
not mating net we can say you know you
have to it's going to end in a mating
net and is the good thing about it it's
going to be similar idea on both sides
if it goes yes in the back excellent
start neither fate is an excellent start
Bravo now
okay quit raise your hand raise your
hand now okay now you can go here right
because of 96 was got two options king
c8 or e if it was to see it what is the
move 396 to GG she's got it yes because
he can't go here it's a fork winning the
rope so he has to go here and now 97
check and checkmate remember this idea
this meeting net okay everybody remember
this net night is covering and the rook
is meeting so now what happens what
happens if he goes here
96 now he's got it excellent he can't go
here because of the mate look th simply
mates he can't go here because check
mate avid so he wins the rook now sorry
and if he goes here what do you do
yes excellent job check-check
and again we see the same exact
mechanism on this side of the board
okay so Rukh at night they can actually
create some things okay they need a
little bit of assistance from opponent
pawns or something but they can create
sometimes the mating net okay so to
excellent exercise for you to remember
how to maneuver your knife when you have
a knight on a chess board
you've got a lot of options with that
Knight okay use it you know that's why
they say Knight needs to be in the
middle of the board right why why it
needs to be in the middle of the board
like in this position it's on d7 right
that's a pretty central good square
because it has how many squares yes six
at the moment you know but more in the
center more threats you will have okay
okay very very nice very nice let's do
one more one more position and again
we're going to be doing the endgame
status on this one let's see I would
like to find a really good one for you
here I've done all of these studies
about 1,000 of them and that's this been
part of my homework when I was you know
growing up and trying to get study I'm
using a very very old book that's got
some incredible positions in it it's
over 30 year old this book okay alright
excellent position so we need to find a
way to we need to find a way to win we
are white and what can we try to do to
win this
he has the extra pond and he has some
you know potential threats I mean if
this King was escaping he would win this
game okay if his King was escaping he
would win this game he would be
victorious
okay what do we do
what
why to play and win no no no too early
too early you I don't think you have
everything this is very strong this is
the most difficult one you've seen today
for sure there are a couple of
incredibly difficult moves you're going
to have to find inertia but once you
find it you'll be able to win it again
we are trying to win but it looks like
he might be trying to win if his King
comes in here right he's a pawn after
all so he might be trying to push for a
victory
you have it all right let's go correct
answer correct answer yes he is
threatening he is threatening check
check mate check check mate but the
question is do you see what to do
against this guy this is the key move
that we needed to see because it's
extremely difficult move now that you've
got to find don't rush I recommend not
rushing here because it's a very very
important moment a shish kebab tactic
yes so that's the idea that's what you
see cannot take the pawn with the king
because of the skewer ideas ok skewer so
that's good that's important to know ok
that means what are we going to do
we have a student in the back yes Queen
B five she say but you see this move did
you see this defense aha
that is the special defense okay all
right King D six now right now but I'm
afraid you don't have a threat you see
if you don't have a threat I will play
this fool and start checking your King
don't think you have a meeting threat
here I might be able to survive this one
you're getting very close to very close
to the solution and he's got it Queen b3
yes threatening threatening Queen d5
checkmate the punish immune yeah cannot
be taken because of the skewer threat is
coming the only way to stop it is to go
check King D 8 D 6 now Queen C 3 sorry
it's black to move still we're down to
parts and it looks like his Queen is
right next to him how could we possibly
checkmate him here but either he's gonna
get checkmated or he's gonna lose his
queen okay save the queen was this
direction how you going to win ask win
one two one two you
absolutely
so that's not going to work what else to
do so it has to go this direction right
away this this is a very nice mate you
see the mate now absolutely Queen
so it has to go here now check continue
continue one more check he has to go
here continue when sister couldn't be 5
11 eternal now if he goes here now what
we gonna do check its mate and if it
goes now to a7 King c7 absolutely now
King cannot go anywhere and threaten
Queen b6 chick so he's gonna get
checkmate this is you need to remember
this position because it doesn't matter
how many pawns he has as long as you
cannot check you is unstoppable made
from here or here yeah yeah like I'll
show you what we're talking about good
job let's look at one more time to make
sure everybody here got it alright so we
start out with which move to that thing
that I made so has to go here and the
second move was a very difficult move to
find Queen b3 good job on finding this
one this is very hard to find now
threatening mate and now this is a
pistol you're losing position now it
goes here check check check
you just need to remember this and
mating lettuce - okay so this is just
remember this position okay this could
happen in a position where the opponent
has a a or H passed pawn he promotes
into a queen but then your king is
closer you go check check check closer
and win the game like for example I'll
just show you one example so you are
playing let's say with the yeah you're
sure in this position so this is the
position you
let's say just plate like you just it's
it's it's black to move here so black
just similar position black just Queens
and now if you keep checking it's not
gonna do much so you have to just make
which quiet move King g3 and now he's in
a mating net from where he simply cannot
escape from or do anything yeah so yeah
so that forced to promote in like that's
going to resolve into a checkmate okay
so excellent job guys today so what I
want you to do I want you to do some
more studies okay
and I will give you a couple of names
right now so you can write down and try
to remember okay these are some of the
best study composers right now so one is
pair back off and pericope is very good
you know Russian composer and you know
his studies are very popular by the top
layer so it's very good pair back off
coup Bell is is the older older
generation throw it ski treat ski has
some great studies Kasparian this book
I'm using is a Kasparian book or
Hendrick kasparian he was the world
champion in this studies okay so this is
gonna you know it will help you with
your imagination with finding a lot of
interesting moves and you know winning
positions that you don't think there is
a win okay so that's why it's very
important other compositors geek has a
lot of good studies geek so you know and
some of the studies I was showing you
they were like from 100 years ago or
maybe even more but the beauty is still
there Reina